hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream 114 q and also a
and a cat to boot not just a cat not
just a cat this is fairfax all right our
epicest tabby
the most epic of our tabbies of which he
is the only one but he's still epic um
unfortunately that also makes him the
least epic
yeah that's sad but no he's the most
epic let's just we'll yeah we'll lean on
the coverage there um
tweet the hashtag go truck yourself
with a link to go fund me
that would be great for a link to go
fund me uh a uh to have to tag them tag
go fund me and tag their awful tweet if
you want but anyway you know use your
creativity but uh go truck yourself with
all the words capitalized camel case
style
um that would be really
cool and i forgot to mention
in the main live stream the alex antic
episode of dark horse which is out this
week which i've only begun to listen to
but so he is a senator from
i don't remember what state in australia
i do but i'm not saying okay
no i've
i've forgotten we covered it in the
podcast and i knew and then i know and
you recorded this a while ago there's a
lot a lot of water has gone under a lot
of bridges since then a lot of water has
gone around a lot of land masses in this
case also australia um i'm sure they
have bridges in australia i don't know
about that really okay
um but
yes check out that episode all right
we've got questions yeah we're gonna
have to come up with some answers we do
we do
um okay uh the discord this week offers
us a choice between two questions
um and um frankly guys this weekend i
don't like either of them so i'm going
to read them both and let you choose
wonderful usually i i really like the
discord questions but uh and you know
part of it is just like obviously if you
listen to the
mainstream today
my head is in a very different place um
and i just don't even know what to do
with either it's not that i think either
is a bad question but i just i'm not i'm
not there so i'm going to be punting a
lot probably to you today brushes on all
right
pick one
all right one
okay i guess we did it
um
pick one of these questions yes can you
give us a crash course in quasi-species
evolutionary theory in regards to both
the origins of life and viral
application
right
and two
uh it's a small question if you could
make one change to the us constitution
what would that be
uh the font
no um they're just sir
no no no no no okay go yeah you're so
big and
here's the problem the u.s constitution
got a lot of the values right it has
some myopia in it
um which is unavoidable because it is
of a particular moment in history but i
do think
the biggest error in the thing and i am
ready to discover that this is just that
i've spotted the one failure mode and
the other failure mode is equally as bad
you know so basically the point is the
whole thing needs to rethink
not because the values are wrong but
because it's not up to the problems of
the 21st century
but
the most glaring problem is
that the first past the post system
creates a
duopoly of two mind-numbingly wrong
positions which are constantly battling
back and forth
and
so anyway
a a structure that created a you know
something closer to a parliamentary
uh order where you had power sharing
agreements that
destabilize the duopoly would i think be
superior but i recognize there are
problems in that too
and i would say it is time for us to
think of a
a structure that properly honors the
values that were correctly identified
and so boldly identified in our
constitution
um and figure out how to deal with it
that said i've also
frequently mentioned that i believe a
constitutional convention at this moment
in our history would be a complete
disaster so i'm not arguing let's open
up the constitution and do better i'm
arguing that we have a problem because
uh this brilliant document is showing
its age
good well done thank you
first question from
darkhorsesubmissions.com today
is there an evolutionary benefit to
being offended or being offendable
i can think of nothing else in the
universe that is offendable only us
humans i do not use no i do not see any
benefit to this attribute but maybe i'm
missing something if it is indeed in
that negative perhaps instead of trying
to eliminate everything considered
offensive humanity should indeed instead
strive to become so offensive that
people are no longer offendable would
love to get your thoughts on this so i'm
going to let you riff but first i will
say with regard to anything else in the
universe
um being offendable
um other primates get offended you can
you can see this um like baboons and
certainly the other apes um
when uh when there's a breach of the
hierarchy or of the food sharing rules
or
or some such and because we are so
closely related to them
we can see this in their sort of shared
facial expressions and as such i imagine
that although it'd be less hard to
less easy it'll be more difficult to
tell
um with organisms that share
fewer of our
sort of social cues but some of the
other long-lived generational overlap
social long childhood organisms like
elephants like wolves like dolphins like
parrots like crows i'll bet give and
take offense but you know what would how
would you know in a dolphin i don't i
don't know you know we've known people
who spent time studying the social
behavior of dolphins and maybe they
would know but certainly it wouldn't
show up the same way as it does on us
because they have a different
um
we have we have a most recent common
ancestor with dolphins it's a long way
back and before we ended up with um
quite so many of the facial muscles that
we have
yes
i know there's a good joke and how would
you know if a dolphin was offended i am
not quick enough on the draw today um
all right so you know you get to the
meat of the question right well let me
just say yeah you're right about uh
other primates showing offense slow
lorises in particular
yeah they're very quick to anger in many
circumstances it's amazing they actually
managed to petition to get the name slow
loris it's sort of a it's a bait and
switch you meet one you're like wow that
was
i didn't expect that from you slow loris
right exactly um yeah we actually have
not been lucky enough to meet any slow
lorises laura all right lorax
no that's a different thing okay um
[Music]
yeah obviously offense is adaptive it
passes the adaptive test with flying
color i will say obviously it is should
be presumed to be adaptive it could be a
byproduct of something that is adapted
but clearly adaptive evolution built it
and given its nature as a cognitive
phenomenon it would be so easy to purge
it from a person and you would get a lot
of advantage out of not being offendable
so clearly the advantage of being
offendable must outweigh the advantage
of not being offendable otherwise it
would go away rapidly
so what's the what's the point well
all emotions are a proxy landscape
for
[Music]
calculations about what one should and
shouldn't do in other words the sum
total of all the calculations of your
perception of where you are
socially environmentally and all the
rest gives you a guide for how to
act right you find something you know uh
tantalizing and you go towards it and
you find something horrifying and you
recoil and um that's how we function
right we are not automatons we
function based on the sort of comparison
of these values and they lead us to
overcome our fears or to you know be
dominated by them or however it works
but
the point is
offense is part of a calculus if you're
talking about offense not like an
offensive smell but if you're talking
about being offended at somebody's
comment for example
then what you are doing is you are
creating something in the neighborhood
of an imagined
debt right when somebody offends you
what it means is something beyond i
disagree with what you said
but i am troubled by the implications of
the fact that you said it right
so um you know a racist comment for
example may indicate that somebody
harbors a belief system
that i don't know imagines that their
population has inherent superiority
right so you would take offense at it
and the point is that offense
then
uh i think the point of defense is a bit
durable
when you say you are offended what you
mean is five minutes from now this is
not going to have
vanished because time has passed the
point is i'm actually noting that and
i'm making a kind of permanent note that
it is an indicator of something and it
might be that it takes three or four
such notes to really realize yeah this
person does have a defective model in
their mind compared to what i think
reality looks like after a certain
number of iterations you go from i'm
offended to i think you're offensive at
least to me
yeah you do and the point is it adjusts
your context maybe the point is well i'm
hardly going to trust this person with
such calculations or i don't think they
can be trusted with power or
resources or something like that but
anyway it's part of an accounting scheme
as the basic point and it is it i think
it has a connotation of durability which
suggests that this is not a momentary
it's not like um you know when somebody
bumps into you on the subway right
you're not offended they may in fact
have been callous but the point is it's
a very temporary thing the offense is
durable inherently and i think that
indicates something about it that's good
that's a good answer
next question
what's the proper mental model for
someone in the u.s who was vaccinated
with fizer almost a year ago but not yet
boosted as to how they should approach
their defense to covet if not yet
infected
i'm especially interested in one any
updated thinking ray
uh dr vandenbosch is thinking that is
would my natural immunity be blocked by
ineffective vaccine-learned antibodies
that's not the end of the question but i
don't see anything in the question up
until now that says anything about
natural immunity so i don't know exactly
anyway
um
one
is there any updated thinking regarding
dr van bush's thinking would my natural
immune to be blocked by ineffective
vaccine-learned antibodies
two effective okay two effectiveness of
vibramectin if i could get it due to its
mechanism of action being spag protein
related if i recall correctly
there's a lot in there
um
um
there's a lot in there and i forgot to
turn off my phone
with just quickly because there's a lot
here uh with regard to the effectiveness
of ivm
and mechanism of action being spiked
protein-related uh as if i remember
correctly there are several
mechanisms of action with regard to ivm
um
not all of which involve spike protein i
don't remember what all of them are
um it has been proposed uh that ibm is
less effective against omicron than
against the earlier variants that hcq
might actually be more effective
um
that's all that's all i got on that yeah
i would say
it's pretty clear that it is less
effective it was also less effective
against delta than it was against the
alpha variant and that meant higher
doses were necessary to get effective
prophylaxis
in the case of
omicron it is a useful therapy but is
not decisive in the way that it once was
as far as we can tell
as for the
question of does your vaccination have
an implication for what kind of natural
immunity you would develop
if and when affected which must be what
you mean yeah i think that's right
unless you're talking about innate
immunity which is different yeah um
then
the answer is yeah there are several
mechanisms by which that could be the
case i don't think any of them are
decisive or likely to be decisive but
you have original antigenic sin which is
effectively the fact that the immune
system gets tracked into certain
responses and that the the vaccines will
track it into a response that is less
and less useful and thereby
presumably will have some effect so to
the extent
that when you get sick
your body will be exposed to many
antigens one of those antigens is spike
and the vaccines have already informed
the immune system about how to respond
to spike and so they may that particular
fraction of your immunity may be
unproductive
might you not expect though that given
that the extent vaccines are so much
less effective against omicron than
against earlier variants
that um
antigen enhanced immunity is did i get
that right uh
no no
ade antigenic
dependent
antibody dependent yeah no that's not
that's not
you're talking about original antigenic
original antigenic sen um might also
given that the extant vaccines were
formulated for earlier variants and they
don't seem to be very effective against
omicron you might expect also that
original antigenic sin would be less of
a problem
for omicron
well
right i mean i think that logic holds i
think that logic holds too but i'm not
even sure it matters because the basic
point is the one of the reasons that
these vaccines are so feeble is that
they are so narrowly targeted and so
even if
your original antigenic sin misleads
some fraction of your immune response
that is spike targeted if your immune
system is responding to antigens across
the entire pathogen then the point is
okay maybe it's
four percent less effective probably
below the threshold at which we could
even easily measure it even if it's
present
so you're kind of arguing original
energen might may be less of an issue
regardless
because these facts for for these
vaccines because they are so narrow to
begin with well it depends i'm not i
guess i'm not sure what your argument is
why is it coming up here why is it
coming up here as an answer to the
question about um
vandenbosch's uh hypothesis about
because there are multiple mechanisms
whereby they're so i guess i'm
separating effects that are likely to
matter from just effects that are likely
to exist okay and so to the extent that
this is an abstract question well no
he'd be like
not really he's and what's the proper
mental model like you know how should he
behave given i think the facts i had a
year ago now i think the proper mental
model is yes there are ways that this
could potentially have that effect no i
don't think any of them are likely to be
significant enough that they would have
that they would alter your behavior or
your concern about contracting the thing
we haven't seen the indication
of you know a
you know an ade
situation strong enough to matter in
other words you'll probably still get
omicron because your vaccine isn't very
effective at preventing it
you will probably develop
very durable immunity from having
gotten it and your vaccination could
have some small effect on that process
but i wouldn't expect it to be major
fair enough
with great power comes great
responsibility
joe rogan critics say is somewhat valid
criticism
oh
i'm going to punctuate that differently
with great power comes great
responsibility joe rugging critics say a
somewhat valid criticism but the podcast
conversation format is incompatible with
requiring extreme scrutiny since
improperty discovery is an essential
part of the process and the reason
people love the format how can these two
worlds be satisfied
um
i don't think it's even hard
yeah i'm not i don't
i also don't think i see the conflict i
mean it's not if if the argument on the
great power with great power comes great
responsibility side is honestly a you
can't ever put anything out there until
you're certain
that doesn't make any sense at all and
that's maybe that's a straw man of the
statement but it does seem to be the one
that those who would say well you can't
you can't have impromptu conversations
or would seem to be standing behind
right i mean first of all there's a
distinction between
power and you know does joe rogan have
great power they certainly reach a lot
of people all at once you know is there
power in that yeah but that's not what
that statement means with great power
comes great responsibility joe has a
tool which is to persuade people
right that does not have the same kind
of implication as somebody who wields
great power to dictate you know
the law for example not saying it
doesn't carry any responsibility but
basically what kind of responsibility
does it carry for a guy like joe
well i think it carries the
responsibility that he be open to
discovering that he isn't right that he
not be a dick that he air in in the
direction of generosity all of these
things he slam dunks right every single
time by virtue of the fact of who he is
when he sits down in his chair and he's
no more that way now that he has the
power of a gigantic audience than
presumably we didn't know him back in
the day but he's so clearly authentic
like he's just so clearly the same guy
he's been and he's learned he's grown
and all of this as we all hopefully have
um but he's not become a decent guy
because he now has power he's just a
fundamentally decent guy and that's part
of why he has gained the audience he has
because people can see it i mean you
know i would i would also just point out
um authenticity is the coin of the realm
and there's a reason and the reason is
because [ __ ] has become so dominant
right so you know
cnn and cdc and everything that is
broadcasting garbage
you made joe rogan this powerful and
important and the reason is because he's
not a dick and he doesn't lie yeah i saw
i mean i didn't i didn't say in the
first part of the podcast um
this clip from what is it morning joe
that i tweeted out this week i think
or no i actually put it into one of my
sub stack posts
um i don't even remember what their
names are the host of morning joe and
it's their not a show i've ever watched
but jose
but and
micah something so it's the woman who's
doing most of the talking in this clip
um
and uh they're the two hosts
um
it's disgusting it's totally
reprehensible um the way that they
characterize what's going on in ottawa
uh and
you know by
all most most metrics that i can think
of or that someone who was thinking
about power those those buffoons those
[ __ ] yahoos
uh have a lot more power
um
you know by any certainly by any metric
that existed until five minutes ago um
sort of in media space
uh then j rogan has and they are acting
beyond irresponsibly like they are they
are just
lying left and right and making [ __ ] up
and um
you know and slandering
really good people
yeah but you know look
consistency is uh
the essential element here and you know
they obviously
suck and they're behaving in a
despicable reprehensible way
but
is that great power
no
they have great i mean it's one of the
i i don't know
i've never watched morning tv but it's
one of the big morning shows right
so what i'm not gonna hold anybody whose
uh power is yapping
uh to some different standard i guess my
point is here's what you don't get to do
you don't get to
be really terrible at persuading people
and drive your own audience away because
you make them sick
and then have them go to somebody else
and then get to attack to somebody else
for being successful and persuading yeah
yeah yeah right yep so yep
good
do you think it is fair for certain
scientists to lambast religion for
extremist behavior and deaths caused
when darwin's discovery led to the
spread of eugenics which caused millions
of deaths in the 20th century
i think that's a non-sequitur
i do think that
certain scientists and that's not in
quotes but i sort of imagine the scare
quotes around that
lambasting religion are doing so
unfairly but it's also true that
religions
many religions many times in history
have used as some of their methods
um
you know genocidal tactics
and you know that has been part of
explicitly part of some some
some religion
whereas um
taking a misunderstanding of a
scientific discovery
and using it for ill
you cannot be held responsible for the
misunderstanding and misattribution of
of all of the ideas that you put out in
the world downstream
well i actually
put more stock in the parallel here than
it sounds like you do although i think
in the
in both cases
there's nothing to it right religion
doesn't lead people to genocide what
happens is there is a genocidal
evolutionary process
that
builds itself into the culture that
surrounds it and this is part of the
problem is that it's not like that thing
has gone anywhere so the danger of
genocide continues to exist
and it will be dressed up in different
clothes so i guess what i'm getting at
but i mean but some some religious
uh
dictates specifically are about in group
versus ad group and chosen people and if
you're not chosen
we can treat you how you want right but
you will notice that the same thing is
happening with all of these secular
folks we're watching the exact same
instinct that's true i don't yes but
that's a non-sequitur no it's not really
no my point is the creature has that
instinct to find a vulnerable
antagonist and steal their [ __ ] right
that's built into the critter
and the fact that the critter also takes
whatever it does and justifies it in
religious terms
is interesting and of course meaningful
but it's not that the religion is
causing it it's that the evolutionary
dynamic is dangerous okay so so you're
arguing
we're going to do it regardless we need
a system um that keeps you know keeps
our better angels uh front and center um
i still think there is a distinction
between
um a
a scripture that actually argues in
favor
of killing
and a scientific understanding of the
world that can then be utterly
bastardized you know eugenics
which sometimes um goes under the large
slightly larger banner of social
darwinism has is is a bastardization is
a misunderstanding of darwinism social
darwinism is not darwinism well social
darwinism is a stupid low quality
instantiation of something okay
okay but you know there are a lot of
stupid low-quality instantiations and
my only point would be
okay we're going to
uh say that it was the religion that
caused this genocidal impulse that
exists whether or not people are
religious
that doesn't make sense to me
are we also going to then recognize
which i believe we should
that there is a process by which that
religiosity upgrades itself and that it
has gotten more humane
right if you look at you know the old
testament and then you look at the
editions you know if you take the major
editions from
uh
from the new testament right you've got
uh the story of the good samaritan
um
the point is
you've got the golden rule you've what
you've got is a increasing inclusivity
of the in-group and ultimately i would
argue you probably arrive at some
version that looks like buddhism where
the idea is yes actually
we're all in the in group and then aha
maybe it doesn't even stop with us maybe
we have to treat the biological envelope
of the world as part of the in-group
right and i believe that this is a kind
of enlightenment and it will get encoded
in enlightened
religious philosophies if that's what
you want to call them and so the basic
point is look let's stop [ __ ] around
we're talking about the underlying
but i mean seriously we're looking at
the underlying evolutionary program
and you know what the underlying
evolutionary program has some really
vile stuff in it it also has the
capacity to overcome that for very good
logically sound reasons yeah right and
so i don't want to
claim that the place in which humans
store their list of do's and don'ts is
the problem when the problem is what are
the do's and don'ts and you know
should we blame you know should we blame
the languages that people use in order
to organize a genocide right i wouldn't
blame the language that that that seems
like a weak comparison i don't think so
i don't think so you're talking about
how human beings encode meaning and they
encode meaning philosophy but sets of
instructions or sets of instructions and
language is a tool by which you can say
any number of things and if you're being
encouraged to you know go out and kill
your enemies right but the point is
religions do multiple things and to say
that this religion you know has these
bad things in it well it also has some
good things in it and the same we can
say the same of language
so anyway
i don't i don't think we can say the
same thing in languages
because it's too stupid but my point is
it's stupid if you do it with yes i
think so right it's stupid when you deal
with language and it's obvious that it's
stupid it's less obvious with with the
religions no but religion is a set of
interlocking narratives with you know
different degrees of truth and morality
to them and language is the building
blocks of those narratives it's the
language doesn't have narrative
as part of what it is
i mean language is one of the things
you're no more likely to tell a
genocidal story in english or norwegian
or ojibwe or i don't know malagasy i i
bet you we could do we could figure out
how often somebody says something
genocidal and it would not be evenly
distributed across languages for sure
not
right and so believe me my point is this
is a reductive ad absurdum i don't want
to see us deciding that the language is
at fault because i don't think it is i
also don't think the religions are at
fault because what they are really doing
is taking underlying very dangerous
evolutionary processes and building them
into a metaphorical structure that
people operationalize without knowing
what they're doing but
the real problem is hey there's a
genocidal instinct inside of people here
are the conditions that cause it to
emerge right yes it will be phrased in
religious terms and
um when it's not phrased in religious
terms because we're not religious people
we're going to build something and then
clever people and i believe me i say
this with uh with with tremendous love
in my heart for you but amanda left
coast will then say well wait a second
i can map religion exactly onto this
right you're talking about secular
scientific stuff but you're the position
you've taken up is a religious one here
let me draw you the map right and the
point is
we just took a step that i thought you
were going somewhere and you went
somewhere totally else
amanda describes the public health
insanity and she says this is a religion
let me show you yeah and then she draws
the map right and she explains what the
connection is and my point is
she's not wrong
this is a completely secular landscape
that actually just happens to map
perfectly onto religion because the same
things that cause people to instantiate
things into religion are being activated
here and they've invented a religion
that doesn't have a name
so
i
i think i agree
i think i agree with
all or almost all of that but i still
see a distinction between
this story says go out and kill people
and this discovery was then
misinterpreted and that
misinterpretation said go out and kill
people those are that's and that's just
there's a step removed there's really
freaking important
yes sort of except
the problem is well no i think
biologists spend way too much time
comforting themselves about um the fact
that social darwinism
isn't darwinism and the point is it's
crappy darwinism right but so is a lot
of stuff we do
and i guess you could argue that
religion is crappy darwinism and that
this feels unuseful to me
i don't know why you would say that
uh
my point has been actually
when we talk about the content of
religions we are talking about evolved
stuff that is about advancing genetic
interests so yeah it's social darwinism
right right but but then there's there's
no information at all in saying well
this is downstream of evolutionary
thinking
but this is kind of my point right the
question asked
should we hold religions responsible
right should we hold darwin responsible
and the point is i don't think we should
be holding people responsible and then
you're arguing for not holding religion
sensu lotto responsible but you can
still say that religious scripture right
there said go out and kill people and
that's not okay and you can also say
social darwinism is is making
exclusionary arguments and it's insane
and that's not okay right 100
so
so my point is it's not
darwin isn't responsible for
so you're you're you're talking about
religion with a capital r
and i read this as
um
in in particular instantiations of
religion but if we you know if you know
science big s isn't responsible religion
big r isn't responsible
but particular instantiations of
religion
do in fact describe instructions for
terrible behavior and particular
instantiations of you know eugenics do
as well
but that isn't but those particular
instantiations are not the same thing as
darwinism
that's the step i don't get okay so my
point would be i've been saying since
i've been since i was a college student
as you know yeah these are underlying
evolutionary drives and we have to
recognize what they are if we are to
prevent these very bad processes that
rep that applies to warfare it applies
to rape it applies to genocide these are
evolutionary processes that we have a
responsibility for stamping out
right
in order to stamp them out blaming well
you know that's bad darwinism that's the
problem no it's not bad darwinism
somebody made the i mean look somebody
could make the argument right hey
people with this eye shape share more
genes with us than people with that eye
shape let's get rid of the people with
that eye shape that's not a bad argument
from the point of view of
the genes and what they want it is a
despicable argument from the point of
view of decency
and so the fact that yes but social
darwini or
i guess eugenics is specifically what's
what's been raised here but um
social darwinism
which i guess i've thought more about
than eugenics because eugenics is so
obviously immoral
social darwinism makes the error of
imagining that because you've succeeded
in business basically because you or
your parents acquired wealth you were
therefore more fit it is a fundamental
misunderstanding of what fitness
um
is with regard to it being context
dependent right so
i mean i think we can solve this this
way
the social darwinists
have an argument about superiority yeah
it's a garbage argument the genes are
all about getting into the future
whether superior or inferior sure the
example i have used is if you have two
versions of an enzyme for respiration
and one is five percent more efficient
than the other that's the superior gene
from the point of view of what the
enzyme does in a context
the enzyme that doesn't do it as
efficiently still wants to get into the
future and exclude the alternative but
you you've buried what i think is the
lead there like five percent more
efficient obviously you know you're the
master of trade-offs you know that that
comes at some cost doesn't have to
doesn't have to because
if we're not at the efficient frontier
right there you go there you go so
all i'm saying is
evolution is playing a game about
getting spellings particular spelling
but but we know that that particular
example that you give does exist there
is variation that you know people who
live in the himalayas have oh gosh i
can't remember and we read about in the
book but um you know a genetic
difference that allows them to collect
more oxygen for this it's a hemoglobin
difference but i don't remember the
specifics and um it's better for them
yes it's not better for them if they
decide to move to sea level then there's
some cost associated with it and i don't
remember what it is but there's some
cost associated with so it's there is no
universal most fit is the point it's not
there's no universal most fit there is
however better and worse and not all
variation is about that in fact most of
it isn't most of it's about trade-offs
between different habitats and things
like that but they're you know look
human beings ended up with big brains
why did we end up with big brains
because we could do more with them than
the little brains that preceded them
right there was a superiority thing and
the reason that all humans have big
brains is because they were better than
all of the little brains that preceded
us true for every human yeah so
the point is there's better and worse
but that's not the game evolution is
playing better is a means to an end and
this is this is so but it's also totally
context dependent
no
there is better and there is worse and
there is also context dependent right
the vast majority of what we see the
variation between species is context
dependent but my point is
beyond this
selection is using better as a means to
an end and the end is absolutely
irrelevant to any of the things that we
decent human beings care about getting
spellings into the future is not a cool
game right the fact that some spellings
will get into the future because they're
superior
is a game that naturally occurs but the
point is a gene that sucks still wants
to get into the future right the t
haplotype tells us this t haplotype will
sabotage the mouse that it's in in order
to get into the future it will sabotage
the fitness of the animal because that
gene
doesn't want anything but it behaves as
if it wants to get into the future and
is willing to
have the organism that is transporting
it pay a spectacular price in order to
do it right that's the stupidity of this
game from the point of view of you know
morals values meaning all of the stuff
that we ought to be focused on sure and
so my only point here with respect to
this question is
i don't think we should be holding
darwin responsible for either the good
instantiations the accurate
representations of how you might get
your genes into the future or the stupid
lame incorrect ones i don't think we
should be holding religion with a
capital r responsible for the genocides
that are done in its name or the
the
alternatives the point is these are
structures yeah i guess i but i mean i
still just disagree that darwin never
pretended to be trying to do that right
and particular religions exactly are
trying to do that they're not even
pretending they're not okay
so like i mean it's the stated purpose
of one and it's exactly not in any way
the stated purpose of the other right i
agree with that and so there's what
you've just said is
you've got a naturalistic fallacy the
idea that you're going to do anything
other than treat darwin as a description
of how things function is automatically
a misuse of darwin that's interesting i
wouldn't have thought to phrase it that
way but i guess i think that's right i
think i think that's what you're saying
and i agree with that and then the
question is why am i making that move
with something that is explicitly about
right and wrong right and the reason
that i'm making that move is because you
have an evolutionary process
upgrading the software right some
religions suck more than others right
i'm much happier with a buddhist
instantiation where we not only include
everybody but we think about including
you know the biosphere and all of the
stuff that we're dependent on because
actually you know what that's a bit
enlightened right it may sound weird it
may sound woo-woo but the point is yeah
you're going to destroy the earth and
include all the people that's not going
to last very long right so
anyway point is i do think there's an
upgrade process there's a process of
enlightenment that is also written into
religions and so i'm not saying
you don't have barbaric religions that
view other people as not real and
you know you do and genocides happen on
their watch and we ought to be trying to
bring everybody to a place of
enlightenment where we recognize
actually you know what it is better for
us to co-participate in something right
to agree on rules that don't advantage
anybody and to say hey
we're pretty lucky to have a planet you
can even be on at all we're pretty lucky
to have happened right let's make the
best use of this we can and let's
preserve it religion based on the and
what is it the anthropic principle right
exact anthropic religion would be
a cool thing
all right well okay cool let's move on
sure
um
i watched a bit of viva fry's interviews
in ottawa today including the counter
protesters
the prevailing theme was the jab as a
civic duty versus bodily autonomy this
feels like a fundamental debate of
collectivism versus individualism
opposites but both essential how do we
bridge the divide
this is
a huge and difficult question and here
here's the wrinkle right and heather and
i have been we have tried to be very
careful never to embrace this pure
bodily autonomy position because it
isn't right there are cases in which you
might have to mandate something now
although i will admit
that seeing clips of trudeau go in my
body my choice back when he was
whatever the [ __ ] he was before um is
jarring and enjoyable well because he's
such a hypocrite
the the
this two-year process has
pushed me to recognize some things that
i didn't know before one is i don't
think i've seen a government structure
that is free enough of corruption that i
would trust it to override bodily
autonomy doesn't mean i can't come up
with a thought experiment in which it's
actually necessary for our collective
well-being and ability to go into the
future that something be mandated but i
don't see the government that can be
trusted this is huge yep
a lot and a lot of people i'm in the
same camp as you know but i think
we're by far not alone right
but so okay let's agree to two things
one let's leave open the possibility
that you could have a structure that
trustworthy but that we haven't seen it
and we can't even prove that it's
possible it may be that it's not
if that's true then the bodily
autonomy thing has to has to govern yeah
and as um
i've forgotten his name the um
the
this only living member of the of the
framing of the canadian charter uh who
argues that what's in there says
individual first and then the group to
which the groups to which you are
members to which you belong
right now i i do think this is kind of
an inversion right as we were talking
about in the in the main podcast
at some level every decent society has
to prioritize future generations right
and you know most especially ones that
are already present on the planet
because
it's very hard to do well by people who
will live seven generations from now but
it's pretty
it's much easier to deal
with children who actually exist i don't
but i don't think children are even
referenced in that like you're not yeah
but they are because
you know
your genome
gets divided into and the point is you
get atomized you don't necessarily yep
there's no
we're not talking about atomized genomes
here okay no we're talking about a
heuristic he's saying individual first
but why are you doing that
so so you didn't listen to the whole
his whole speech but you know that that
particular quote is just about
individuals and the groups to which you
belong
you know okay so you know you as a child
may have certain things but like
generally you're talking to adults and
adults aren't members of the
groups that are children and so there's
nothing in that that says you don't
actually need to prioritize some groups
of which you may well not be members
i mean i just don't think it's even
responsive to that i think you know
needing to protect children is not um
addressed by that particular
quote i'm not so sure about that okay
i'm not so sure about that because i
think civilization to the extent that we
are
uh
not doing what is necessary for our
children to have an environment in which
they will acquire the things they need
to in order to be healthy adults that's
a collective problem right it's
something we collectively have a
responsibility for dealing with and i'm
not sure that individual well-being
trumps it inherently but
um
but what i want to say is two things one
individual autonomy wins out here
because
not only do we not know whether or not a
government that is capable of
shouldering responsibility is
conceivable or could be stabilized so
that it could
continue to exist but we certainly know
that none of the governments on earth
can shoulder that responsibility because
they're all so [ __ ] corrupt
but
the second we know the second thing is
the
logic
of these mandates is so bad
that the point is it's not even that the
group's well-being has been prioritized
over yours it's pfizer's well-being has
been prioritized over the group and you
and your children and every other thing
and the point is that is just completely
illegitimate at every level yes you have
the right to say no to a policy that is
pfizer motivated yeah
no it's i mean it's it's actually
remarkable how there seems to be like no
way in which you can argue in favor of
the the government's right here to
mandate these things they're
you know and especially if we just talk
about you know for for children
yeah they're not safe
they're not effective
they're not necessary
that's it
yeah like it's you know it's it's for
it's for a disease that barely affects
children
it's a treatment that is dangerous for
children
it's not effective for anyone
particularly
in uh keeping away disease except
perhaps for the very old and those with
comorbidities
so
that's the thing they're going to
mandate well again you know honestly if
if you can mandate that what can't you
right but we've got to draw the circle a
little tighter right i agree that
children are the place to focus because
it is so obvious in their case but the
vaccines that they lied to us and told
us prevented the transmission of disease
and now they swear they never said that
but of course it's been caught so many
different places that it's obviously
just a lie
but those vaccines which do not prevent
the transmission of disease we are now
told you should take to protect you from
serious illness
right
these healthy kids don't get serious
illness from kobe that's right what's
more and if what's more you cannot
protect the people who do get serious
illness by vaccinating children right so
right the point is it doesn't stop
transmission right so why would you
accept even if we didn't know there's no
collectivist argument to be made for a
treatment that doesn't stop
transformation there's no logical
argument to be made in this case it is
strictly a matter of you have been told
something vague about what the good
people are doing and you've been told
that the more of it you do the gooder
you are and therefore we are going to
vaccinate your children and that is
insane
yeah you get more good points for the
more children you vaccinate the more
times
or maybe it's the exact inverse
do you think mirror universe gaslighting
might be a good term for the inversion
of the truth that brett mentions for
instance looking at one thing and
responding as though
you're responding to the opposite
mirror universe gaslighting
i like it
yeah there's something
both
so just
relevant to our discussion of
both the media coverage of
the black lives matter protests that
regularly turned into riots in some
cities including portland uh two summers
ago and the media representations of the
trekkers convoy that's happening right
now the the protests in ottawa that are
happening right now that are
extraordinarily um
kind and caring and humane and you won't
hear that on msnbc that's for sure
yeah there's something
there's something quite quite right here
mirror universe gaslighting it is
it is
yeah the
my concern about it is that it's not
self-evident what it means but there is
something about the idea
that you can know right away that um
you know the autonomous zone in seattle
is a glorious utopia
and that the trucker convoy is white
supremacist and violent
um because of course it would have to be
that way wouldn't it
um and you know it's a problem that the
facts on the ground tell the opposite
story but it's not too big a problem if
you've got you know
if you've got enough of the
impression-making apparatus ready to
repeat it sure
yep
trade-off
i'm not yet sure what this means i'm
going to read it i'm trying to read my
punch
trade-off colon
it's logical for immunosites to push
themselves to exhaustion yet some leave
progeny
how might cellular society honor valiant
service
all right here's what i think
this person is missing
and it's really one of the most
important things to understand
to understand any
complex organism
which is
the reason that an organism works
is because
all of the cells have the same genome
and the only way that genome gets passed
on is if the gonads end up in a position
to
create gametes that then get a shot at
finding a corresponding gamete so what
that means
is that your
i assume we're talking about brt cells
here
don't need a reward because their reward
occurs when the critter whose immune
system it is
successfully
reproduces and they're perfectly happy
to go out of existence and um
i hope i hope that's an answer to the
question that was asked i'm not 100 sure
i understand the question but
maybe the question is really about how
do we take the analogy of what happens
in the immune system and apply it in
civilization
that hint sort of exists in there but
yeah i don't know but basically the
point is that
um
what we really need for people to
understand is that
we will have done our job well if there
are still
people living on an earth approximately
this good or better 200 years from now
okay next question
um
we've got
a lot of questions we're not going to
get to so let's try to move fast
although this next one is
involved
couldn't each of the aerosolized
airborne studies be explained by droplet
or surface fomite spread
they each are very inconclusive
so this person is speaking to two
studies and we don't have the references
here and it's been a while since i've
looked at these so we're just gonna have
to take his word i it's gonna be hard to
respond because i don't have the
references in front of me nor have i
thought about them recently
restaurant study author says quote we
agree that virus transmission in this
outbreak could be explained by droplet
transmission the possibility that
persons move around touch surfaces go to
the restroom engage in close contact end
quote
in the church
study this is not a quote but this
person writing the questions summary of
the church study the organist was the
first in church touched the doors
um oh a third one choir studies snacks
were shared had breaks
um the ro is the r naught is closer to
how it's pronounced right or not
r naught is closer to non-airborne
sorry's cov1
than it is to measles
oh why there's just i i do not remember
enough of
the logic here to be able to respond
with savvy yeah i'm not sure what the
question is how how do we rule out
foamite transmission yeah or draw or
droplet
it's so it's so there's a couple of
there's
two hypotheses uh with three different
sources of possible evidence it could be
droplet it could be phone might spread
rather than aerosolized airborne
um i guess four there's three studies
and then that the r naught is closer to
non-airborne stars kv-1 then measles
but i yeah because art is is there's one
definitely not airborne too
so
first of all
i don't think the comparison
to measles is fair because so much of
the r knot is tied up in all kinds of
subtleties yeah um about how the viral
particle interacts with the cell surface
and all so anyway it's not it's not a
gross parameter that we can just subsume
that yeah it doesn't map on from one
variable
yeah but the other thing is you know to
the extent that the evidence for things
like uh air circulation is good
that strongly indicates that it's in the
air not on surfaces
although it doesn't perfectly indicate
it because there's a confound and the
confound
is well i think the confounds are part
of what the person around the question
is pointing out
well i would just say if
if the if this was fomite transmission
you would expect air circulation to be
less effective than it is you wouldn't
expect it to be a non-issue for two
reasons one if you have air circulation
you would expect you know a certain
amount of the potentially infect
infectious particles to float out the
window for example and two more
importantly probably you would expect
the drying effect of having greater air
circulation to destroy some of the
potentially infectious particles on
surfaces but you still wouldn't expect
the kind of effect that we see for
greater air circulation yeah okay
to
i'm just going to read it to mr brett
weinstein
i want you to listen to
this links in germany right shuster dot
d e and
they're the most proper links for this
time in germany i'm sure that you can
help they can help you if you need this
for
sincerely
walking so that's just links i guess
i'm i'm as interested in
german links as
links from any other part of the world i
just i think feelings are cool
have recent events
you didn't like that one bit no
well i was because i'm bored i'm like
are there links i'm sure they're i don't
think there are links in germany you
don't think so i don't think so i bet
you i think they're asian in origin
but i don't know about their
distribution
um
i mean if they're any cats in germany
they're likely to be
so you think bobcats are links no i
don't no i don't know i don't think
there are links in germany is it a
climate thing
uh either climate or vicariance could be
hot links no
we're done
[Laughter]
no
are you done it's okay
have recent events caused you to
re-examine historical events commonly
dismissed as conspiracies for example
the jfk assassination
um
well
uh
to be honest with you
i know this is going to sound crazy but
um i don't think the warren commission
this is an obvious one right this is
just so i read this the first like oh
boy what's going to come like what which
of the things and you know there's some
we're just not going to talk about but
jfk assassination
yeah i know we don't have to reconsider
that i'm not a believer in that
particular fairy tale yeah um
but it's not a question of revisiting it
right exactly i will say the
spectacular level of dishonesty and its
breadth and its um
reach
does
make me
i am i am concerned about the level of
fiction and what it might imply about
other things but
but
no i wouldn't say
yes
i wouldn't say that there are any events
that are
especially changed by this yeah
have you heard about hair loss due to
covet my wife has lost 80 of her hair
after delta
i have not heard this
this is this is a first for me
i have not either yeah yeah
i'm sorry
it doesn't sound like fun although of
all the things that could go wrong it's
yep at least barely aesthetic
and thermal regulatory
um
as oregonians i feel obligated to make
you aware of
hb4079
in three days oregon legislators
legislators are voting on a new sales
tax for the purpose of funding 750 debit
cards to be given to low income
including homeless individuals
please consider joining me and emailing
them to tell them how bad of an idea
this is more information at
oregoncatalyst.com
etc
oh boy yeah that does sound like a bad
idea
yeah that does sound like a bad idea
um thank you all right
we will look into it yeah excuse me
i've just finished reading philip
pullman's la belle sauvage first of his
new trilogy and i strongly recommend it
powerfully opt cool
we read
whatever the first famous one was to our
boys
many many years ago
um his
what is it what was it called
philip
yes
his something something
um
anyway yeah i've actually i saw this
question during the break and i ordered
it so
it's on right
um i stumbled
i stumbled across across a worm with a
bioluminescent portion on its posterior
end why the heck would a worm evolve to
have this
cool um
to prevent rear end collisions
from other worms well right exactly
um
so first of all bioluminescence is so
fascinating as to why it would exist in
the various places it's so much more
common than it seems like it would be
turn off your damn headlamp and stand
there for a while yeah well i don't i
mean interpret for us maybe not
something no it's it exists it's been
tropical for us yeah
and then you also get to be standing in
the dark forest and listen to it come
alive around you so there were um
lots of instances where i was trying it
has to be night time yes to work no it
works perfectly during the day you just
can't see it i don't know they might not
be
is it can you turn it is it an on and
off thing or are they just always there
are on and off ones and there are always
ones
but anyway when i was doing my uh
infrared video work back before it was
so easy to buy a
uh camera with the night shot on it i i
did some pioneering stuff where i filmed
bats with an infrared illuminator which
i constructed and bank surveillance
cameras which are sensitive to ir
anyway
there was a lot of sitting around in the
forest hoping that the leaf i had chosen
to point the camera at would have
something amazing happen under it and
often that didn't work out but i spent a
lot of time sitting around in the forest
at night and well but i mean you're
you're way under selling all parts of
this process but um one of the ways that
you're underselling it is that um the
way that you decided what leaf to point
your camera at was by spending a lot of
time in the forest
day and night basically learning the
natural history of these organisms
making observations um that you know
don't count as data
and figuring out what kinds of leaves
and what sorts of situations some of
which you could have
said if someone had asked you why'd you
pick that one some of which you just
kind of had a gestalt for uh and you
know did you get lucky i guess given
that you were the first guy and maybe
still the only guy ever to record actual
tent making in bats um but that was
hardly all luck no no it wasn't no
there's a lot of hard work that went
into it and but but it's also hardly all
just tenacity it's not just hard work
it's
the you know it's doing the natural
history it's spending the time and
having a feeling for the organism as it
were and uh getting you know coming to
understand why how it is and where it is
and why it is that they do what they do
yep and uh yeah anyway feeling for the
organism as barbara mcclintock would say
a feeling for the organism and a
extensive knowledge of their
structures such that one can see one
that has just barely begun but anyway
the point is sitting around in the
forest with infrared cameras pointed at
leaves which sometimes never had
anything happen near them um
those are some cool leaves
i used to joke that i was working on
plant behavior
documenting it with video but anyway uh
nocturnal plant behavior specifically
anyway the point was during those
periods and fully
well mostly with the exception of that
of the one the sucker-footed bat fully
fully adult leaves that weren't even
like
engaged in tropisms or anything they
were just no it was really lame sitting
there yeah
um but
while i was sitting around i would
sometimes
leave my head lamp off i wouldn't leave
my headlamp off because i was filming
and then my eyes would adjust and i
would see all of the bioluminescence
around me and i would collect it and you
could make a really bright
pile of stuff bright enough to read by
oh you don't really know
not bright enough to read by but
certainly bright enough to entertain a
person with my
weltering nocturnal plant behavior right
now with more video right right
anyway that was a great deal of fun but
there's a question about why so you
should explain for people who haven't
i don't know why there would be any in
our audience but for people who haven't
spent a lot of time uh in sitting around
tropical rainforest at night um that you
know collecting it it wasn't in the form
of worms it's largely fungal it's fungus
yes and so and it's then on dead leaves
you can collect the leaves in which the
fungus is most of it's
it's also fruiting bodies sometimes
decaying wood yeah mostly yeah yeah
anyway um
but there's a question about why a
fungus consuming
wood
needs to put out light at all right i
mean it's a that's an odd thing for it
to do and actually a lot of the
bioluminescent stuff is this way
where it's you know is it a byproduct
well what exactly is going on so anyway
i don't know why this worm was doing
this and i also don't know that it was
the worm it may be that the worm was
infected with something
and that that put a little bit of light
on it
um it's possible yeah but uh anyway yeah
but also i mean just you know
the
one thing that's possible is if it
really is the worm and it's
bioluminescent on the posterior end and
this is a worm whose business end is all
in the front um and worms being able to
withstand a certain amount of having
been chopped off that uh it could be
effectively like eye spots in a place
where your head isn't so that it could
attract predators there as opposed to
the front of the worm
i think i mean yeah i think you're
working pretty hard there
yeah i
you don't like it i
not like i mean i i like it at the the
elaborate nature of the argument appeals
to me i just don't think it's likely to
be true okay well we did you know this
is
pretty bereft of context so uh yeah i
can imagine the scenario in which that
makes sense here's my feeling yeah my
feeling is that we have given this
person
no recognizable answer to their question
but that that was so subtle they won't
notice
never never noticed we're just that good
i think we got away with it yep
i think it is free will versus freedom
that is being threatened what do you
think
free will as i think the verses means
like as opposed to it's not freedom that
is being threatened so much as free will
is the is the proposition here
i'm
i would have to think on
what all i think those two different
terms mean
yeah the problem i'm running into is
that
as as our
as our listeners and viewers will know
i'm not a fan of the concept
that we don't have
free will i think it's nonsense and i
think it has to be nonsense and i think
evolution itself tells us it's nonsense
but
i understand the argument um
and the point is
if we don't have free will then there
isn't really anything
to the idea of freedom how could there
be
and so i'm not sure how you disentangle
these things
inherently
a violation of freedom actually it's
maybe this is what the person is getting
here's what i hope you're getting at
what i hope you're getting at
is that authoritarianism
and tyranny
are
attempts
to deploy
a to short circuit free will
right and the whole point is
you
you have free will and somebody would
like to take away its useful consequence
i'm not sure how to separate it from
freedom but i do think that this is you
know it's like
um
not right i think that that's that's as
good as i can do okay
does one who's had omicron have immunity
to the rest of the code variants
excuse me um it's kind of looking like
maybe not
right i mean i we don't know i haven't
seen
haven't seen data because why would they
share that with us but
natural immunity is well understood even
admitted now by the cdc
to be
effective in fact more effective than
vaccines against future reinfection
um
but lots of people getting
getting coveted now when supposedly it's
omicron that's the thing that's
happening and it's definitely some form
of the disease that is far
more transmissible and less serious as
an illness
lots of people who either um
you know know that they had it before or
or were vaccinated against the earlier
variants and supposed that they were
therefore protected against
those variants
so but doesn't that go the other way
how do we know
whether or not omicron
provides
immunity to other variants
does one who said omicron have immunity
to the rest and so
it's possible i answered the inverse
question i think happened okay um does
one who said omicron have immunity the
rest of the code variants oh yeah i
think i did answer the the inverse um
yeah we have well we don't know and um
and it seems
well yeah it seems like maybe not
so i don't know how we answer the
question with the pre-existing
variance
right i think it's answerable but the
ability to answer it is waning and
future variants don't exist yet right
but like we
if future variants
are actually evolutionarily downstream
of omicron then we should expect natural
immunity to persist
um but if
the new variant comes out of
left field
as omicron seems to have
then we may have exactly the same kind
of situation as we did with the omicron
where it's like well this is actually we
should probably be calling the stars
kovi three or four or five whatever
yeah um you know it's also
the thing about omicron is it's so
effective at spreading
that if it is you know it is possible
that this just simply
controls the
human circulation of this thing right
and you know it could it could become
flu-like where it pops back up
a new variant pops especially if you
know
mouse and
deer and who knows what else reservoirs
right um but in fact that's another
question here um let me just
because
we're running out of time and i wanted
to get to a number of things but where
is it sorry um
wow there are a lot of questions here
i swear there was a question about ah
here stars ii is terrible at outdoor
transmission but um nice and deer are
infected what's the explanation for this
it's a good it's a good question yeah so
it's important there's something not
straightforward about oh no yeah the
mouse and
dear thing we've asked that same
question about outdoor transmission and
deer in particular
um but
there's something that doesn't add up
here either these things were
circulating in these populations before
we knew that they were circulating in
humans and therefore it has had time to
do something else with the mice there's
a strong argument that uh
laboratory techniques involved in
producing this virus as was so likely to
be the case would have involved mice and
therefore adjusted its tropism um
whether they would have you know do the
mice have
the equivalent of an indoor environment
probably yeah um you know a burrow uh do
the deer probably not yeah um so anyway
there's a lot of ways to think about it
don't have an explanation for this yep
um
why do none of the statistics around
cove at 19 include a metric for was
refused early treatment
asking for a friend
oh yeah yeah
i mean i i ended up in a conversation um
with a doctor who was concerned about uh
this is this is a year ago no it's not a
year ago this is last summer uh at the
point that everyone who wanted to be by
then could be vaccinated and at that
point we run prophylaxis ibm
which we since stopped
um and this doctor was very concerned
because another doctor friend of his was
seeing all of these people who were very
very sick
um
with kobet who were in vaccinate having
the
the
glass opacities in their lungs
yeah um and i said to this doctor who's
very very good guy very very smart um
is this is this doctor in this er
supposedly seeing these things in people
who either receive early treatment
with ibm and the other things or on
prophylaxis for it um because simply
being unvaccinated isn't a good group
and um and he acknowledged oh yeah i bet
you know
not separated by that and i'll bet it
looks different once you separate it out
that way and why aren't we allowed
access to those data well that would be
very destructive of certain narratives
wouldn't it yes well we are in fact
having a pandemic of accounting
shenanigans and this is one
yes we are
yes we are um
here's a
terrible gigantic question that you and
i have been talking about an awful lot
and we're not going to spend much time
on right now but i think it's worth
saying and
from it's from someone who asks us who
who we see a lot here um and just say
uh you don't even know what the topic is
yet but i will say
we
will be coming back to this a fair bit
but um
it's a terrible question
what's the deal with the left and
pedophilia
from pro-pedo articles to
maps that's a acronym standing for minor
attracted person which is a euphemism
cover-ups
apologia i never know how to pronounce
that word etc it's an alarming
correlation
furthermore i predict trans and
non-binary will soon be eclipsed by a
push for its pedophilia's acceptance
yeah
yeah so this is a complete disaster yes
those who have predicted
that this would arise have been correct
the scope of it is
quite scary and maybe most scary of all
is the fact that this is now as the
question implies being taken seriously
yeah people think they're being like
inclusive or something
to no i i don't i don't think i don't
that's sort of i think i think i've seen
that in some of the sort of the
so-called intelligentsia
on the left
but there's a question about what it
means that they think they're being
inclusive i don't think they're being
inclusive i don't think they think
they're being inclusive i think they're
being bullied into accepting it because
they will be stigmatized as
non-inclusive if they don't okay well i
think that's the same thing but i get
your distinction um that they don't they
can't quite put their finger on why
you know why it's not a free speech
issue or something and so they say well
maybe it's just a
sexual orientation
yeah we will be returning to this but
let's say that when i said in the main
part of the podcast that we were failing
children on many fronts
this is
uh
one of the most important and
people who think that this is some minor
fringe weird thing ought to rethink it
because this is
heading at civilization like a freight
train and of course our most fundamental
obligation is to protect children
from
predatory adults we do a terrible job of
this it's not just pedophiles we also
don't manage to protect our children
from corporations that study their
behavior and sell them things that are
bad for them and all of that so this is
we have a long history of failing
children in this regard but we're about
to fail them at a new level and it must
not be allowed to happen
uh so
i recommend this zach if you would show
my screen our our friend
who goes by holly mathnerd
uh recently published this on her sub
stack on the push to destigmatize evil
why pedophilia must never be normalized
it's a incredibly difficult essay and
she gives plenty of trigger warnings
like which you should take seriously
yeah this essay
should be read by many people as many
people as possible but it's not that it
should be read by everybody and so
please those warnings are not pro forma
please take them seriously and if you're
not somebody who should read it
don't yep
um but it uh
it
addresses several of the issues raised
by the person asking the question
yep all right
is there a danger of people losing the
will to bring those culpable to justice
as normality appears to return in places
like the united kingdom
yep
yes
yes yes there is
yeah but we got to be very careful here
because
the fervor for holding people
accountable
while there are obviously people who
must be
held accountable in order
and that this does not repeat itself
most people have made an error
and so anyway um i think we just need to
make sure that we do not engage in any
of the
stuff that
tends to afflict people who
um who win a battle
uh okay we're
we're well over an hour at this point
let me just
get a couple more questions in okay
um
another book recommendation have you
read cs lewis's space trilogy i didn't
know c.s lewis had a space trilogy the
third book that hideous strength is very
relevant to today
recommendation taken okay
um
is honey or honeycomb nutritious or is
it just
sugar
uh fascinating question i think
nutritious
uh is too narrow a term i think
um
honey has many known and presumably many
not yet known beneficial effects
including
um
like
anti-inflammatory and immune enhancing
and things like this
that are outside of the purview of do
they give you a nutrient that you can
then convert into energy or build bones
or something with so i don't know the
answer with regard to if we just try to
keep it at like since you strict on
nutrition uh but but
is honey is honey excellent for you in a
way that sugar is not yes so this this
is true i believe it you know at a
simple level it's nutritious sugar is
nutritious well but
is it but that's that's right but that's
my point is that we we do this badly
because sugar is not limiting to us
and so the point is at a technical level
it's nutritious yes the question is does
it differ from sugar you're trying to
give an answer i'm going to answer the
question that should have been asked but
the
there are values that come from
other components of honey but you should
be very aware and i don't know how this
has changed but some
i'm guessing it's a decade ago at least
there was a study done to see
what fraction of the honey that one
purchases at the supermarket is actually
honey and the answer was a very small
percentage in the way that was done was
that it is impossible to make honey
without including pollen
right it can't be done and so what was
what they did was they looked for pollen
in supermarket honey and they found that
a lot of it was sugar that had been
dressed up so that is
particularly bad
but
yeah anyway yes as a substitute for
sugar honey is good because it has other
benefits
how it compares in terms of negative
health consequences to sugar i don't
know i would love to know
a couple more
fyi trudeau brandish blackface twice
high school talent show and a gala in
2001. i believe although i've not gone
looking for um the bit where i thought i
saw this a while back um
that he's actually been asked
just how many times were you in
blackface sir and he's like well geez i
honestly can't remember
um so
i mean it
yeah it's just it's this part is just
too easy the idea that the
guy who's leading the charge of white
supremacy against a bunch of honestly
patriotic and peaceful and wonderful
human beings is literally the guy who's
been in blackface for fun on multiple
occasions
um is
extraordinary yeah so i think we have to
be
quite careful not to say nobody who's
ever
been in blackface can do xyz because of
course there are reasons that you might
like uh the character of roger and
in
mad men for example so anyway it's not a
simple question but i think i am
comfortable with a rule that says we
should not let anybody into power who
can't remember how many times they've
been in blackface i think that that's a
safe
a safe limit to set yeah
okay two more um
one of which is really
a rhetorical question we'll end on the
rhetorical question but we probably
won't leave it be rhetorical because
we're not too good at just letting
things sit are we
um the first one is not rhetorical um my
friend a 45 year old female is active
healthy pro covered backs
this week was diagnosed
and therefore was vaccinated this week
was diagnosed with free blood clots in
her legs no explanation she's scared
likely
it's possible
it's hard to say likely
i mean if that description is really an
accurate
summary of who this person is
i would say it's likely but not certain
yeah um
at some point we're going to talk about
why blood clots because i believe that
there's a
there's a fairly simple way of
understanding this that is not widely
understood
yeah
okay
final question
i let myself get infected in order to
get a health pass and live a normal life
as an unvaxxed living in europe
what does this tell you about public
health policy
thank you both
that's the rhetorical question it tells
me something about europe i didn't know
yeah i think i think that's new i think
that's i think that's
maybe almost brand new i mean of course
we didn't talk about um i believe now
all the scandinavian countries plus
switzerland and
maybe the uk
um have dropped all of the covet
restrictions
but for most of the eu there's still
restrictions but
but this that natural immunity is um
is
good
it
works instead of a vaccine
hell yeah right
right
wow all right well that's great
yeah yeah little little rays of hope
we're getting rays of hope shining in
our window now yes we are yeah into the
internet um
i think that's it all right i think
that's it
so we will be back next week
uh i think same time same place we
haven't
planned it out we're thinking actually
for those of you still listening we're
thinking of
moving our regular time to um friday
afternoon pacific so as to give our
producer
his weekends back
and we know that that will be make it
impossible for people
rather challenging for people in europe
to listen live but um if you have
feedback on that
i don't know where you can send this
maybe you can send it to our moderator
but maybe that's not nice
think on it real hard
see if we can't pick up the vibe
so mean i don't know why i did that yeah
why did you do it i don't know i don't
know i'm sorry
yeah um
all right we will be back next week and
in the meantime be good to the ones you
love eat good food and get outside be
well everyone
[Music]
you